welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show today i am joined by a the uh by
greg knuckles he's currently the
permanent guest co-host for the time
being
if you like the show and you'd like to
support it there are many ways you could
do that you could like rate or subscribe
wherever you get podcasts you could join
our email newsletter by going to
strongerbyscience.com
newsletter you could check out our team
of one-on-one virtual coaches we offer
coaching through stronger by science
with a very talented team of experienced
coaches you can learn more at stronger
strongerbyscience.com coaching you could
use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com
the code is sbs pod
and that gets you a five percent
discount off of your order at
bulksupplements.com
you could also check out the mass
research review at strongerbyscience.com
mass or you could check out the macro
factor diet app that we co-developed
which does offer a free trial
all right greg road to the stage how are
things going
oh uh things are going good not too much
to report this week i was on vacation
through through the last part of last
week just a little trip with
my wife's
uh siblings so i guess my my brothers
and sisters in law um yeah just to just
to hang out catch up reconnect um so
yeah wasn't uh wasn't really like
focusing on the diet just just kind of
doing the whole intuitive eating thing
uh went well
weight was flat so
you know nothing uh nothing too exciting
happened on either the good end or the
bad end uh so yeah that's uh that's my
update
now you mentioned intuitive eating do
you find that you have
improved your ability to kind of eat
based on hunger cues compared to the
past or is it
where are you at with that yeah yeah i
think so um you know honestly the
biggest win
was that like i i don't i don't drink
much anymore and i typically when i do
drink a fair amount uh my my dietary
restraint and dietary choices get much
much worse um but yeah no i i managed to
uh to to stay under control even when
getting pretty lit which was good and on
that note here here's some some life
advice for anyone listening to this
podcast so i i'm 30 now uh i've been
really for probably the last four or
five years this is related to why i
don't drink much anymore used to be i
could have
you know not like a ton of alcohol but
like three four or five drinks and not
get much of a hangover around the time i
turned 25 26
just like two beers like i wouldn't i
wouldn't have a hangover but i'd feel
just noticeably worse the next day and
in like four or five like i'd i'd
definitely not feel that that good the
next day so i was like you know what
it's i still like drinking it's fun but
the impact on the next day of my life
just isn't worth it anymore but i have
found that there's
that there's a hack in the system i i
think i know where this is going which
is sangria which is incredible so uh
spanish people listening to this i'm
sure this isn't the most traditional
approach to sangria but uh here's what i
do it's just a bottle of wines like one
and a half liters of wine or 1.25 just
whatever a standard bottle of wine is
about a quart or a liter of some sort of
fruit juice that's relatively high in
antioxidants so like if it's a red wine
something like uh like a tart cherry
juice or like a pomegranate juice uh
is an excellent choice
and then um
just some sort of like
light uh liquor to bring the abv back up
so like a tequila or a vodka or a mezcal
or something like that uh and then you
know toss some fruit in as well for
additional flavors throw some citrus in
for aromatics it's good stuff
anyway i don't know exactly why this
works i i'm thinking it's just like the
antioxidants from the fruit juice like
allowing the poison i'm putting in my
body to to cause less damage than it
otherwise would but man i can drink a
ton of sangria and feel perfectly fine
the next day um
and i
i really put that hypothesis to the test
over this past weekend and uh
still woke up feeling like a million
bucks so uh
yeah i mean
drinking a lot not getting a hangover
and still making relatively decent food
choices on that note road to the stage
went excellent this past week yeah
you're on a slippery slope right now uh
and it seems to be
a very clear trajectory toward you just
becoming a frugivore uh the people who
eat
exclusively fruit uh i see you just kind
of weaning the meat out of your meat and
fruit diet and just doing uh
fruit and sangria as your diet you know
i i will say if i was someone who cared
less about science and evidence and and
just had more of like a vibes based
approach to how i
uh
yeah like made life choices approach my
own diet
i i would be someone who would be very
susceptible to like frugivore propaganda
cause like
i i want to believe that i could live on
a diet exclusively of fruit i don't
think i can um
like i i think that i would wind up with
quite a few nutrient deficiencies uh
certainly not enough protein to maintain
muscle mass but
uh i wish i was slightly more gullible
because
until i started uh experiencing
you know
like um
what deficiencies would i get probably
i'd probably become um
uh
what is it when your iron's low anemic
yeah i'd probably become anemic i'd
probably wind up with like some b12 [ __ ]
like uh
maybe like a like a magnesium or like
zinc deficiency or something um but yeah
like until all of that stuff set in like
i'd have a fun month
yeah but
yeah whatever fruit's great i miss being
gullible i mean
i miss being extremely gullible because
back in the day i would like
i would switch when i was like really
young from one pre-workout
to a different brand pre-workout with
all the same ingredients and i would
believe that i was trying a completely
undiscovered anabolic like this is going
to be the most potent
muscle building stack that i'm
assembling right now and it was like
carnitine and a generic pre-workout but
every i did that like every two months
and was like man no one knows what kind
of gains i'm about to experience yeah
and i i miss that so i will say like
there's
there's a part of me and i i think we've
talked about this on the podcast before
but there's a part of me that has uh
debated with myself the ethics of
honestly discussing the the beneficial
effects of supplementation because like
you know most things even that do work
will have a modest effect at best but
then when you look at the research on
like the handful of like placebo steroid
studies that have been done like the
magnaris paper from 2001 the aerial
paper from 1974
it seems like expectancy effects
can have like a a huge effect on gains
potentially
and so like if if people can convince
themselves that like they're going to
achieve steroid-like benefits
from
you know
supplements that either are just
straight-up placebos or like might be
somewhat beneficial but they're not
going to have a huge effect but if
people can convince themselves that they
will
uh
you know we we might be robbing gains
from people by disabusing them of that
notion and so i
i'm not comfortable fully going down the
road of like ah ins justify the means
like let's just start chilling
supplements and uh saying they're the
best thing ever but i'd also be lying if
i if i said that that thought has never
crossed my mind yeah no i mean the the
the evidence is strong of like like you
said those papers where they convince
people like we are putting you on
steroids now go lift like you're on
steroids and they're like hell yeah they
get very very strong yeah uh and they
are on placebos which is pretty wild um
all right so
road to athens i've got nothing new to
report i'm having fun love and exercise
getting out on the lake a few times a
week doing some other stuff it's pretty
fun
uh feats of strength what do you got
feats of strength sure so um
let's see so the the couple of big
powerlifting meets recently the usapl
mega nationals and uh
and ipf worlds like you know those
happened recently uh most of the strong
people in the world did their their very
strong things in the recent past so
there haven't been any
well there haven't been many like huge
powerlifting gym lifts in the past
couple couple of weeks you know people
people are just recovering from
nationals and worlds uh so i i dipped
into the weightlifting subreddit to see
are there any weight lifters doing crazy
stuff these days and i came across this
guy he's a lifter from kazakhstan in the
96 kilo class named arteom antropov uh
and what had recently been shared from
him was a 300 kilo double back squat so
that's 661 pounds um i go to his
instagram page though and from about six
months ago he was hitting some just
nutty front squats uh so these will be
linked in the show notes but you will
see a 260 kilo front squat for
a smooth triple uh so that that's
what 573 pounds i think um
and then 281 for
again like a pretty smooth single and
that's
uh
what like 620 something like that yeah
at a at a sub 100 kilo body weight and
he's like 22 right yeah i i think he's
quite young yeah
i watched the video so i was like how
old is he because he i think he's 22 but
i think he looks even younger than 22.
yeah but yeah i was surprised yeah so
very strong and also i mean
i i just love the aesthetics of a
weightlifting squat like i just think
weightlifting style squats look so cool
and i also just think really heavy front
squats are super impressive so uh
yeah uh congrats to him check out the
videos
and you know if you've ever struggled
with front squats and you want to watch
something that will make you hate your
life and feel worthless uh yeah check it
out
yeah
uh all right so for our first uh kind of
main segment of today's show we're going
to do a stronger by science article
discussion so
and this is actually technically not a
stronger by science article this article
is posted at
macrofactorapp.com uh we launched that
few weeks ago right when did we
officially launch that
uh time flies like a month ago yeah a
month ago so this is one of the articles
that went up on the newish macro factor
website
and it's about cheat meals so macro
factor app.com cheat meals uh this is an
article that i wrote
obviously exploring
cheat meals
um kind of from an empirical perspective
so not just saying like i don't like the
terminology but
empirically
what does a cheat meal look like out in
the real world how do people talk about
cheat meals how do people
psychologically
respond to this concept and uh you know
a spoiler alert is that it ain't good uh
cheat meal is generally not in my
opinion an advisable strategy nor an
advisable term for the strategy
so without kind of foundation then i go
into
some different nutrition strategies that
seek to accomplish a lot of what people
are trying to do with cheat meals but
with fewer downsides
and if you're listening along you might
hear some thunder in the background
there's no chance i'm going to try to
edit that out
but you can just as a listener
appreciate that we are battling the
elements trying to deliver great content
here uh so the issues with cheat meals
uh and i'm not gonna make this like an
audio book i wrote this article several
weeks ago i don't have it all like
perfectly at the forefront of my memory
but i want to hit the highlights and and
basically just tell you what the article
is about some of the the main notes and
then if you're interested in digging
into the references and resources i do
encourage you to check out the full
article but
uh the issues with cheat meals
are
numerous really uh i started out by
looking at a study
uh by pilas and colleagues and they were
looking at
um
it was actually a really interesting
study because erpila and colleagues they
were looking at how frequently people
just talk about cheat meals on instagram
using uh the hashtag tool so you can
search a hashtag and figure out okay how
many posts have actually used this
hashtag and they were looking for
hashtag cheatmeal and they were looking
into it and kind of using that as a
jumping off point to explore
what do we see from the people who are
discussing cheat meals and actually
utilizing cheat meals
and there were a number of things that
jumped out to them in their analysis so
first of all uh people talk about cheat
meals a lot on instagram which is a
place that's really instagram is a
platform in which the fitness industry
is really active like there there are a
lot of folks who go to instagram for
fitness
um when they searched it uh back in i
think 2017-ish
they got 1.6 million hits for that
hashtag i searched more recently and got
4.2 million so that alone like that's a
bigger number it is it's gone up quite a
lot um and it was kind of funny because
one of the pieces of um
uh negative feedback i got for the
article was like cheat meals
obviously are dumb
i agree with you that they're dumb but
literally no one talks about cheat meals
anymore that's like talking about
something that died in the 80s and i'm
like
yeah i mean that's just not that's
empirically false people still talk
about cheat meals all the time and
clearly are still using them all the
time
uh so it in the evidence-based fitness
world sometimes we have to get out of
our little tiny
uh corner of fitness and and take a
broader perspective but
without question people are still
talking about cheat meals
and i mean even even if the perspective
is like
no one no one who knows what they're
talking about
uh says or recommends cheat meals
anymore like even if that's the
perspective like
there are a lot of people who don't know
what they're talking about yeah yeah so
yeah like
uh think things that are inadvisable uh
might shock you to learn still still
happen every day they they do indeed um
so
that's kind of the jumping off point for
the article is is looking into how often
are these discussed what does it look
like when someone says i'm doing a cheat
meal on instagram kind of digging into
what what are the characteristics of a
cheat meal and what is experienced by
the person who is implementing cheat
meals and generally speaking there are a
few main issues with cheat meals as
they're commonly discussed and applied
first of all in the empirical literature
there are some pretty clear parallels
with binge eating um and not just in a
superficial way so superficially you
could look at someone who says oh i'm
having a cheat meal check it out and
it's like a 4 000 calorie spread of food
so
on the surface you could say well that
looks like a binge because 4 000
calories is a big meal but what's more
telling is that a fairly common
observation is the experience of
disinhibition during eating which is
basically a perceived loss of control
this is a key characteristic of what
distinguishes a binge eating episode
versus having a big ass meal
when you become disinhibited and feel
like you've truly lost control
over your eating habits
that's when you start noticing like some
of the key signs of a binge eating uh
episode yeah like when you look back and
say like
i didn't need and i didn't really want
that third plate of food why did i get
that third plate of food right exactly
yeah uh and sometimes even while you're
doing it you're like i know that this is
not compatible with what i'm trying to
achieve with my diet
and yet i can't seem to get myself to
stop you know
uh so parallels with binge eating
specifically disinhibition that's a
major issue with cheat meals and i know
some people are gonna say well i have
cheat meals and i don't have i don't
experience
disinhibition and that is great
and we'll talk a little bit about that
later
another issue with cheat meals is simply
incompatibility with an individual's
goal hierarchy and also a misapplication
of the fundamentals of operant
conditioning so
this is kind of two things wrapped into
one but sometimes people will approach
cheat meals
and treat them as goal oriented
behaviors they say as part of my fitness
goal i will also be introducing cheat
meals and so for example they might be
uh pursuing a fat loss goal and they use
cheat meals periodically as part of a
strategy the issue with that you know
we've talked about goal hierarchies
before where you have subordinate goals
that feed into intermediate goals that
feed into a superordinate goal
and the problem is if you have
elements within your goal hierarchy that
are directly contradictory of one
another you can cause a lot of friction
in that goal hierarchy and a lot of
interference where you're
engaging in behaviors that ultimately
are not feeding into higher levels of
that hierarchy and they might really
have a demotivating effect an effect
where you kind of pause and say
i am simply confused by my goal striving
behaviors right now
because there's something something's
not right here there's some
incompatibility and some inconsistency
so ideally you do not want to have major
disruptions or contradictions or gaps
within a goal hierarchy
and when i talk about operant
conditioning so operant conditioning is
an approach to learning or behavior
change that utilizes reinforcement and
that reinforcement can be positive like
a reward or it can be negative like a
punishment and what you're trying to do
with these positive or negative sources
of feedback is you're trying to
encourage particular behaviors
so i was reading a great textbook by dr
edward serafino
and the whole thing is about uh behavior
change behavior modification and there's
a tremendous amount of text about
operant conditioning and one of the
things i find interesting about cheat
meals is people will often say listen
i've been dieting my ass off all week
and i'm going to reward myself at the
end of it a job well done is rewarded
with a cheat meal
and i was like how would an academic who
studies operant conditioning view that
approach and i'm i'm reading through
this textbook and he's got like 12 tips
of like if you're gonna do this here are
12 things to definitely not do
and i'm pretty sure the very first one
was
don't use reinforcers that could work
against behavioral or outcome goals for
instance it is not a good idea to use
sweets as a reward for meeting sub goals
in a diet program to reduce caloric
intake so like if you look into books on
operant conditioning this concept is
literally the top example of what not to
do and so a lot of times people who
promote cheat meals are like come on you
should reward yourself with this
and it's going to be something that kind
of keeps you engaged in this goal
and
all the evidence that we have
empirically would suggest that that is
the complete opposite of what you would
want to do
that now you can use operant
conditioning very effectively you can
implement different types of rewards but
if you're doing a fat loss goal or a
calorie reduction goal the reward should
not be directly
opposite of what you're trying to
achieve with the goal it should be
something that is completely uh it could
be completely unrelated that's a good
way to do it where if i have a
successful period of dieting i'm going
to reward myself with like a self-care
day or an extra date night or you can
work something into it that doesn't
directly take away from the behavior
that
allegedly earned that reward you know
um another major issue with cheat meals
is i also just love the fact that it
sounds like it was just like a listicle
that showed up in this textbook chapter
what
oh yeah yeah yeah
12 tips yeah
maybe maybe my brain's been rotted by
fitness content
are you are you sure this wasn't an
article from dr edward serafino you
found on buzzfeed
i believe it was a textbook i was
holding it
it was several hundred pages long
and there were no pictures so i believe
it was a textbook
um yeah
another major issue with cheat meals in
my opinion is that they
almost by definition reinforce rigid
cognitive restraint so we often talk
about rigid versus flexible cognitive
restraint
and with rigid cognitive restraint kind
of the easiest rule of thumb when you're
trying to figure out am i employing
rigid cognitive restraint to my diet
a really easy kind of test for that is
like am i dichotomizing something that
probably shouldn't be dichotomized that
shouldn't be overly simplified into two
discrete categories right so with a
cheat meal it almost insists on a
dichotomy between being on the diet
versus off the diet because if you
weren't off the diet i'm not really
certain what cheat would would signify
like what is to cheat on a diet while
still being on it that doesn't really
make a lot of sense to me just from a
terminology perspective yeah um so it
kind of reinforces this idea that you
know
you know six days a week you're on the
diet and then you have your cheat meal
or your cheat day where you go off the
diet and then you get back on
but it forces you into this kind of
rigid dichotomy
and very frequently you're going to see
instances where people say yeah
rigid restraint kind of worked for me
for like six weeks
but then once i slipped up one percent i
was officially off the diet and i said
screw it when you're off you're off you
know and it kind of gives way into these
really larger deviations from the diet
and more prolonged lapses in that goal
striving behavior so it can be very
demotivating and kind of open up this
bridge by which you kind of take an off
ramp and say yeah i had been dieting
pretty well but once i slip up a little
bit i'm officially off diet and once i'm
off i'm way off uh so
rigid cognitive restraint we've talked
about it before uh helms had a fantastic
review paper where they talked about
this
and
all the empirical literature related to
rigid cognitive restraint would suggest
it can be used effectively in short-term
interventions so like you know you'll
talk to people who do a ketogenic diet
not because it suits their preferences
because they heard you're supposed to so
they do a ketogenic diet and they say oh
yeah i love the keto diet i'll do it for
four or six weeks at a time lose 10
pounds immediately regain 10 pounds
because i can't sustain it in the long
term and then maybe i'll do it again a
few months later you know but it's this
kind of rigid thing where you're on the
diet it's not sustainable once you go
off you're way off
so
generally speaking
we would prefer not to introduce
unnecessary instances of rigid cognitive
restraint
ideally you'd want to have a more
flexible approach in terms of cognitive
restraint and to be clear
there's unfortunately a bit of a
misnomer this is something that comes up
a lot
oh sorry i didn't finish that that
argument i was making there uh so rigid
cognitive restraint like i said it can
be used in short-term settings and yeah
people will achieve some goals in the
short term but it's not sustainable in
the long term once people go off they go
way off and the empirical evidence would
suggest whether you're interested in
attaining a goal related to diet or just
enjoying the process flexible cognitive
restraint is the way to go it seems to
be positively correlated not just with a
more successful diet and actually
attaining the goal you were striving for
but also much better quality of life and
much better psychological outcomes while
dieting so for many reasons we want to
encourage flexible cognitive restraint
rather than rigid uh what i was getting
at there's a bit of a misnomer that
flexible dieting means that you just
have macro targets uh and by definition
now you're using flexible cognitive
restraint uh another great point that
helms and his colleagues made in that
review paper is
you can absolutely approach macro based
dieting with rigid cognitive restraint
so like if you are if you have a set of
macro targets and you set completely
unrealistic expectations for how closely
you have to hit those targets every
single day and you're stressing over it
and every time you miss by a little bit
you say well i guess i was not adherent
today so now i'm gonna just go off diet
and say screw it i mean that is using
rig rigid cognitive restraint in a
paradigm that seems like it'd be more uh
more suitable for flexible cognitive
restraint so
cognitive restraint is about how much
you're you're just kind of locking
yourself into rigid rules that are often
dichotomized so adherent versus
non-inherent versus you know with a more
flexible approach you could say oh i was
off by one percent i was off by three
percent i was off by
six percent you know there's gradation
to it and being a little bit off is not
an indicator that you should say well
screw it diet didn't work today so i'm
gonna go ahead and keep you know going
beyond these targets
uh now another big issue kind of the
main focus of this paper it's going to
be a bit difficult to describe here i
would definitely encourage people to
check out the written article because it
goes into this more methodically
to try to put all these pieces together
but there's something called the
abstinence violation effect and a
closely related topic which is aptly
named the what the hell effect
and so basically
uh there's a fantastic
book that i reference a textbook that i
reference from someone who specifically
studies she's an academic who studies
uh the psychology of dieting
and uh
she she puts together a really good
working model that frames dieting within
the context of
almost kind of related to addiction
literature where there are lapses in a
particular goal and also kind of more
prolonged relapses where someone uh kind
of fully goes off diet and has what you
might call motivational collapse
but within the article i kind of draw
out within this paradigm of lapses and
relapses i draw out the psychological
ramifications of implementing cheat
meals within the context of rigid
dietary restraint or rigid cognitive
restraint and i talk about how a small
lapse which might be triggered by a
cheat meal cheat meal that goes just a
little bit out of hand can invite all of
these negative psychological processes
that very substantially increase the
likelihood of collapsed motivation and a
full-blown relapse which they would call
the what the hell effect where you
basically say you know what i screwed up
my diet the last two days what the hell
this diet just isn't for me and you are
in a full-blown relapse where you have
abandoned that goal and the goal
striving behaviors for people who are
interested in checking out that textbook
was it health psychology by jane ogden
yeah jane ogden um yeah i i really enjoy
reading her work about the psychological
aspects of dieting it's her focal point
in her research and it shows she she
writes about it with a level of
expertise that is really difficult to
find in the literature a very
uh a very comprehensive approach that
integrates a lot of different models
which is very impressive when you read
it
so
cheat meals generally speaking set us up
for a lot of potentially negative
psychological outcomes uh and ultimately
psychological outcomes that can
directly interfere with our ability to
successfully
uh seek and attain a particular goal
with our diet so in the article i
proposed two options that i think are
better options
one is planned hedonic deviation
and this is uh pre-planned ahead of time
you are selecting a particular day or
potentially a couple days throughout the
week i think it most feasibly on a low
calorie diet you're probably going to
select one day a week where you have a
pre-planned increase in your calorie
target that is purely for convenience so
we're not making it some kind of like oh
i'm doing a refeed because i need to top
off my glycogen it it purely is you know
i have a social event
or i just want to cut loose and
incorporate some extra foods that i
would typically not be able to
comfortably accommodate with my my
current calorie target so planned
hedonic deviation in the article i go
into detail about how to do it the key
differences between a planned hedonic
deviation and a cheat meal because there
are some pretty important distinctions
but what's really interesting about
plant hedonic deviation is there is some
empirical research indicating that it
enhances
self-regulatory ability levels
enhances
the retention of motivation across a
diet
and it can facilitate greater
self-efficacy while dieting generally
speaking within experimental
interventions it's been shown to help
maintain self-efficacy and motivation uh
and while a cheat meal can detract from
that a planned hedonic deviation that is
carried out effectively can actually
have the opposite effect and have really
positive psychological consequences
compared to just doing straight dieting
with the same uh weekly calorie budget
so in the article i go into more detail
about exactly how to implement that and
what the key differences are but planned
hedonic deviation we've discussed it
before on the show it's a fantastic
strategy
another great strategy that i like is
slack with a cost
another term for that is emergency
reserve but i don't like that term for
this because
i don't see any need to bring the term
emergency into the mix i just don't like
what that does psychologically
we're kind of replacing one
slightly disadvantageous term with
another there
so slack with a cost is great i also
like the idea of a calorie reserve
rather than an emergency reserve
but basically what you're doing with
this approach is you're setting an
ambitious goal for your calorie target
and your rate of weight loss we're
assuming it's a weight loss goal in this
context but it can theoretically be
applied in other contexts as well but
what you're doing here is you're setting
a calorie target for for each day but
you have this reserve of calories that
is there if you need it and it's
budgeted effectively so even if you use
it it's not like you're taking huge
steps backward it's like
maybe a calorie budget that puts you
into a smaller deficit but still a
deficit for the week or maybe it just
brings you up to maintenance for the
week and you say okay no steps backward
but no major steps forward that's
totally fine but you've got this calorie
reserve and you can tap into it as much
or as little as you want throughout the
week and you can allocate it throughout
the week as much as you wish so you
might get to wednesday and say
uh for whatever reason today i'm using
my whole calorie reserve for the week
you use it up and then you get right
back to dieting you know there's been no
no explicit deviation from the plan you
had this reserve you used it no big deal
um and if you wanted to you could also
kind of allocate it throughout the week
or only use part of it it's just there
as it's almost like an emergency fund
with finances where it's like i want to
keep that there just in case i need it
and sometimes i will have a financial
issue where i need to tap into that and
use some of it uh but the reason it's
called slack with the cost is because i
think this is actually
i think this actually effectively uses
some of those concepts related to
operant conditioning to some extent well
you know we talked about how
you want to make sure that everything is
in alignment you don't want to have like
a reward that opposes your goal i like
the fact that slack has a cost here
which is that you can tap into it and
use it it's there to be used if you need
it but you understand that if you use
that you are slowing your rate of
progress toward the goal to some extent
it's not necessarily you know grinding
your progress to a halt but there is a
cost to using that emergency reserve uh
very
liberally and frequently and so you are
in this case instead of having this
weird incentive where you diet in in see
as you're seeking a reward of a cheat
meal that kind of opposes your goal you
have this reserve here but you
understand you know it's there if you
need it but as you use it more it is to
some extent going to slow you down a
little bit so you are incentivized to
only use it when you feel like you
really need it
so i think it better aligns that idea of
these extra calories that are actually
aligned with the incentives that match
your goal
so slack with a cost again a really
fantastic alternative strategy rather
than cheat meals so i would encourage
people to check out the article for an
even deeper dive
i tried to get into a lot of detail and
cover a lot of things that people might
have questions about
um feedback generally has been pretty
positive
there have been some instances of
negative feedback
one has been
this garbage ass article is just a big
sales pitch
i mean so first of all you don't need to
buy
any product or service to use any of
this information so i i don't think it
really makes sense to call it a sales
pitch um but since it's on
macrofactorapp.com i did explain in the
article how a user of macro factor would
incorporate that into how they use the
app
but you can use this without the app
this is this is just free stuff use it
if you like uh
some other negative feedback some people
are just like dude i really love cheat
meals that's fine uh if you really like
them go for it i just it's not my
preferred strategy for the reasons that
i lay out in the article well and i mean
one thing i i noticed is a lot of people
well i mean there wasn't a ton of
negative feedback but of the people
giving that particular piece of negative
feedback uh if you ask them a couple
follow-up questions
more often than not what they were doing
was planned hedonic deviation they just
referred to it as cheat meals so it's
like oh well
you don't actually disagree then like
you just like the cheat meal terminology
which
you know is fine we're not here to
police language but
uh you know may not be the best
terminology because the the mental
associations you have with cheat meal
which you know you're conceptualizing it
as something you do
one one time per week it's still under
control it's still in keeping with your
goals like you know
if that's what you're referring to as a
cheat meal but then you go on social
media and say oh yeah i have a cheat
meal every week it's awesome helps helps
keep me on track you should try cheat
meals you know maybe like half of the
people who read that will
also just kind of like implicitly adopt
a plant hedonic deviation type strategy
but half of them would be like oh yeah
like hell yeah i'm i'm gonna
one day per week i'm going to go eat
whatever the [ __ ] i want in a completely
disinhibited way and
this guy who's like pretty jacked and
pretty ripped says that that's good so
like cool i'm gonna go for it and and
when you're dealing with a
d with a ambiguated term like cheat meal
that is the cost that comes along with
preserving that ambiguity so
uh like
one of your points in the article was
just that um you know for for the just
for the simple purpose of clear
communication uh it might behoove you to
disambiguate terms a little bit yeah
yeah and people will see like
dwayne the rock johnson like he he had a
few uh popular posts where he would have
like
like four pizzas and like a bunch of
pancakes lined up and it's like i don't
know maybe you shouldn't plan your
strategies based on what works for the
rock i think he's kind of
a unique case uh also i'm still annoyed
that he didn't respond to any of my
emails about co-hosting this show
his manager
really fumbled the bag on that that's
true um but no
that was like the third piece of
negative feedback i was going to mention
is that like
people are like this is a useless
article because i use cheat meals but
actually they're planned hedonic
deviation and like my response is like
that's great because you're doing a
thing that i think is helpful and useful
um but like you said i think it's odd to
call that cheating if it if they're
if it's done in a planned way that's
strategic and controlled and in line
with your goals i'm not sure what what
you're cheating on in that particular
application
and also um
what you're doing
with that cheat meal doesn't seem to be
consistent with what the empirical
research indicates most people are doing
with cheat meals you know it doesn't
have any of those characteristics that
lead me to say hey
the way that people are engaging with
these four million posts on instagram
doesn't seem to be particularly
constructive uh so yeah if you're
listening to this and you say well the
way you describe plant hedonic deviation
is exactly how i do cheat meals and the
cheat meal terminology doesn't bother me
personally i think that's fantastic but
i would also encourage people to
consider uh you know perhaps when you
reinforce and perpetuate that language
there might be people for whom that has
an unintended negative uh negative
effect uh and i'm not gonna like you
said we're not here to police language
or tell you what you can or cannot say
but generally speaking with
communication the goal is to be uh clear
and to kind of accurately describe what
you're doing and certainly uh it seems
odd to be going around saying like ah
i have
no regard for any unintended harm about
what this term might do i just think
there's a lot of people who there it
would appear empirically that a lot of
people are going to misinterpret that
misapply the concept of the cheat meal
and ultimately it's not going to be to
their direct benefit so i would
encourage people to uh i mean say
whatever you want to say you know
but but i i would encourage people to
consider what might be the impact on
people who are
less experienced with dieting who come
across my post and might totally
misinterpret what i'm talking about here
and in that case i think planned hedonic
deviation if nothing else it's uh a term
used so infrequently that you almost
have to say what the hell's that
like like a person is not going to
intuitively uh associate all sorts of
misconceptions with it because i don't
think anyone has a pre-existing
conception of what plan hedonic
deviation is yeah yeah for sure um all
right so yeah if you want to check that
out it is macrofactorapp.com
cheat meals and there's a hyphen between
the word cheat and meals
all right moving on greg you've got a
research review i do i do so i have a
little research review segment on
the effects of taking time off from
training
i
prepared this segment by accident almost
so
a couple weeks ago alex polish from
barbin.com
slid into my inbox and said hey would
you mind answering some questions about
the effects of taking time off from
training we're doing an article about
this and i said yeah sure i'd be happy
to answer these questions and uh i put
entirely too much thought and time into
answering the questions to not repurpose
it as my own content uh so
yeah the the bar bend article is out uh
it's a good article uh it will be linked
in the show notes um but yeah figured
you know what may as well talk about
this on the podcast as well and uh there
might be a stronger by science article
on this topic coming out uh in the next
in the next couple of months as well
we'll just see
uh but yeah so
this is something that uh several people
have been asking about recently i i
think just because summer is coming up
and so people are going to be going on
vacation they're not going to have
reliable gym access and so they're like
ooh
man i'm i'm going on a two-week cruise
am i going to lose all of my gains or
just like what what are reasonable
outcomes to expect from
uh taking
between like a week or up to a month off
of training like what what can i really
expect
and so i think the best place to start
when answering that question is a 2013
meta-analysis by
i'm going to pronounce this bosquet but
it could be bouquet
i don't know if it's french but anyway
the title of this meta is effective
training cessation on muscle performance
a meta-analysis
and uh
you can you can
well
if you know how to get access to
scientific articles you can check it out
it's not open access i'll i'll leave it
at that
but
the the picture uh painted by this
meta-analysis is pretty straightforward
um so it was it was
interested in muscular performance not
hypertrophy
but it found that
uh it found that in effect uh force
output just like maximal muscular
strength is preserved pretty well uh
up to a month uh of trade
up to post one month of training
cessation uh or yeah like two to three
weeks if you want to be really
conservative about it the the effect
size associated with up to 28 days of
training cessation is a trivial effect
size on average so less than a d of
about 0.2
or so um and like i said the the bosquit
meadow wasn't also looking at
hypertrophy but i strongly suspect that
it follows a similar pattern where
losses in actual contractile tissue are
probably minimal up to a month uh post
training cessation uh just because like
you know force output is the product of
motor skill and just how much
contractile tissue you have your motor
skills aren't improving when you're not
lifting and so if you're only
experiencing a trivial decrease in force
output i can't imagine you're actually
losing that much contractile tissue
either so
for for up to a month uh you don't
really need to go to the gym you're not
going to get that much weaker you're not
going to lose that much muscle if you
perceive that you are
it's probably mostly an illusion so when
you're training consistently um
you know more
one you're just getting more blood flow
to your muscles because they're uh
they're more metabolically active from
recovering from training two muscle
glycogen levels are probably elevated uh
to some extent over what they would be
if you weren't training uh and three you
know just from uh like inflammatory
stress you're causing with training your
muscles are probably at least a little
bit swollen a lot of the time
and so you know if you don't go to the
gym for a week or two you very well
might look like you've lost a lot of
muscle but that's that's probably just
reductions in muscle hydration um where
as soon as you start lifting again your
muscles will go from looking flat to
looking full again and you'll realize oh
yeah i haven't actually lost any
meaningful amount of contractile tissue
and same thing for strength if you're
out of the gym for two weeks you go back
your first session feels like [ __ ] you
haven't actually gotten weaker
you know you probably are just dealing
with some rusty motor patterns and the
very next time you do those same
exercises again they'll feel
considerably better so
for up to about a month you don't have
to worry about it that much
and then after about uh a month of
training cessation that's when
reductions in force output power output
and uh like sub maximal strength
endurance performance
really start dropping off so you know i
i shouldn't need to tell you this but if
you don't lift for six months you're
going to lose a lot of muscle you'll be
a lot weaker
but i don't think you need science to
tell you that
however there are uh several important
considerations here so one
is age very important so the the bosque
meta
uh did it did a really nice job
of doing sub analyses to see
how training cessation affected
like different things differently so you
know do you see different rates of loss
of strength in untrained lifters versus
trained lifters after a period of
training cessation is it different for
young versus older adults is it
different for upper versus lower body
and most of these sub-analyses didn't
find any any huge differences but they
did for age so in studies on people
below 65 years old
and you know you're dichotomizing a
continuous variable it's probably not a
hard cut off at 65 but basically for for
younger folks um
you lose strength at a slower rate with
training cessation you can probably hold
on to strength for a longer period of
time of training cessation for older
adults uh strength
and just general muscular performance
drops off quite a bit quicker when you
stop training
and just looking at the effect sizes
it's it's about a two-fold difference so
it's that's pretty notable so
uh you know if we're using one month as
kind of um
kind of a touch point here maybe for
older adults and maybe you can get away
with two weeks out of the gym but uh may
not be a bad idea to not go longer than
that for younger adults maybe you can
get maybe you can get away with up to
six weeks or two months uh but yeah so
reductions in performance will be quite
a bit quicker for older adults than
younger adults and i i know on the
surface uh some older lifters are gonna
hear that as bad news but i also think
it's important to acknowledge like
two weeks is probably a lot longer than
most people expect when they're having
this conversation oh yeah like i i'll
get questions from people who are like
hey
i'm gonna be out of the gym for five
days how screwed am i and i'm like
literally none at all you know yeah yeah
for sure uh another factor to
potentially consider is what your
training leading up to your time off
looks like so one one thing that i'm
asked with some regularity is like hey
i'm going on vacation i'm going to be
gone for a week um what if i do an
intentional uh overload block for the
week or two weeks leading up to vacation
will that allow me to to
basically use my time off more
productively for recovering and maybe
come back
stronger and bigger than i was when i
left instead of
experiencing trivial reductions in
muscle and strength and there's some
evidence that that could be the case so
there was a study by
bjornsson and colleagues which will also
be linked in the show notes uh they did
observe
uh delayed
uh supercompensation of both
strength and hypertrophy um
so like they they were taking muscle
biopsies for up to 10 days after the
final training session and they were
looking at changes in quad strength for
up to 20 days after the final training
session and they found that uh the the
lifters were actually stronger 20 days
after their final training session than
they were like three days after their
final training session and they didn't
take a biopsy 20 days post but they took
a biopsy 10 days post and muscle fiber
cross sectional area was actually larger
at 10 days after the final training
session than three days after the final
training session so this study found
that in principle super compensation is
possible but it's also worth noting that
the that the training sessions uh
leading up to it were pretty nutty so uh
the subjects in that study were just
doing quad training and uh it involved i
believe five days straight of like four
sets to failure every day and then for
the last two days it was two a days so
basically like monday tuesday wednesday
you come in you do four sets of quad
training to failure uh all three of
those days and then thursday friday you
come in in the morning do four sets to
failure come in the evening and do four
sets to failure so that's
that's a really high volume of training
for a single muscle group uh where does
that
you know
where where is the line so like you know
that's clearly past the line where you
can uh see some super compensation but i
imagine no one is going to keep up that
training schedule for every muscle of
their body for a week straight leading
up to a vacation so i don't know if this
is a feasible strategy to to attempt to
employ and even if it was feasible i
don't know how advisable it is um
just because it will probably entail
a pretty huge elevation in total
training volume over a pretty short
period of time which may be associated
with increased injury risk so
at least in theory the the concept of
attempting to to overload to get some
super compensation uh with a week off
there is some amount of empirical
evidence backing it up but i still don't
know how advisable it is and like i said
if you're just taking a week or two off
you're not you're not really leaving too
much on the table to begin with so i
personally wouldn't worry about it but
you know if you're if you're trying to
dot all of your t's and cross all of
your eyes and you're really concerned
man i really don't want to lose any
muscle or strength uh with a one week
vacation you could try like really
really going hard in the week before
that vacation but again i wouldn't
necessarily recommend it yeah i used to
like kind of placebo myself
with that approach yeah in the sense
that like
i'd be like you know what
i'm gonna crank into that higher gear
this week in training like i wouldn't do
any kind of extreme like
doubling or tripling of my training
volume or anything crazy like that but i
would just try to you know maybe give it
a little bit of you know an extra set
here or there you know pushing the
intensity a little higher here and there
but but yeah i doubt it really did
anything physiologically but it sure
made me feel better
yeah i uh
i
had got probably one of the three
hardest deadlift workouts of my life uh
the day before an international flight
good because
i i was like i'm leaving the country uh
i'm you know it was it was two days of
travel and then in in the foreign
country i didn't know if i'd have gym
access i was like yeah i'm i'm really
gonna go hard on this deadlift session
and just hope that carries me through a
week without lifting
would not recommend that like dude i
like i i didn't hurt myself but my
my spinal erectors between the deadlift
workout and just
the the shit-ass ergonomics of plane
seats like i was experiencing doms in in
my lumbar erectors for like eight days
yeah it sucks that they didn't uh
consult with any human beings when they
designed every plane chair yeah it would
have been cool to have somebody take a
seat on one yeah one end uh wouldn't be
the worst idea so yeah so so two two
considerations one age two what sort of
training you were doing leading up to
the time you take off and then three and
this is the most important by by far
is what the details of that time off
look like so
uh
going back to something i mentioned
before age continuous variable and maybe
shouldn't dichotomize it lifting not
lifting sounds like a continuous very or
sounds like a dichotomous variable it's
not a perfectly dichotomous variable uh
it's still it's still a continuous thing
there are different gradations of not
lifting so
uh the the bosquit meta was looking at
studies where you know it's essentially
people are going about their day-to-day
lives and then they lift weights for a
while and then they just go back to
their day-to-day lives so it's like kind
of normal training cessation uh nothing
too wild happening they just go from
lifting to not lifting but still living
generally normal lives and i think
that's what most people have in mind
when they talk about not lifting however
like i said there is still a continuum
so on one extreme side not lifting could
involve complete immobilization or bed
rest so you know you're you're not doing
arm training anymore because you broke
your arm and it's in a cast or you know
you're you're on bed rest so that is one
extreme of the not lifting continuum the
other extreme is
still lifting a little bit
but you know not nearly as much as you
were before
and so uh the the different sides of
that continuum can have very very
different effects on what you can expect
during a period of training cessation so
uh if you just
come like if if you're on bed rest or
you're in a cast or like a limb or joint
is completely immobilized
you can and should expect
like a truly precipitous losses in
strength and muscle mass so uh this will
also be linked in the show notes a
systematic review by campbell and
colleagues effective immobilization on
neuromuscular function in vivo in humans
a systematic review
and this was a really good review paper
there were a lot of interesting
neuromuscular outcomes worth looking at
so things like uh like twitch force uh
uh like relaxation rates all all sorts
of stuff uh but for our purposes just
kind of like the gross outcomes like how
is muscle force doing how is uh muscle
size doing
it it seems like with complete
complete joint immobilization you can
expect to lose
up to half a percent of your muscle mass
in that limb per day
and you can expect to lose
uh up to one percent of strength in that
limb per day so if you're in a cast for
a month you know uh
you're like if if your arms in a cast
when when you get out like your biceps
might be 15 stronger and 30 percent
weaker which is
way way larger reductions than you would
expect just going from like lifting to
going about your normal day-to-day life
but then on the complete opposite side
of the spectrum
you know you're not going to the gym
anymore but you're still
doing some sort of resistance training
you can maintain basically all of your
gains for
a very very long period of time so there
have been quite a few studies on this
one of them will be linked in the show
notes it's by bickle and colleagues from
2011 exercise dosing to retain
resistance training adaptations in young
and older adults and so in this training
basically they had younger adults so
people from 20 to 35 years old and older
adults people from 60 to 75 years old
trained for 16 weeks so train for four
months and then have a period of reduced
training volume for eight months and so
during that eight eight month period
they reduced their training volume by
either two-thirds or eight-ninths
and what they found is and and so you
know we're talking about like a 70
reduction in volume or like a 90
reduction in volume and they found that
for the older the older adults they
could reduce their training volume by
two-thirds and still maintain muscle and
strength for eight months so that's
that's a a large reduction but still
doing about a third of what you were
previously and and maintaining virtually
everything for the younger adults
that that eight ninth reduction doing
just one ninth of the training volume
they were previously was sufficient to
maintain or even slightly increase
strength and muscularity over eight
months so
you know if you're taking
if you're taking a month out of the gym
like you're you're going on the vacation
of your dreams or just you're burned out
and maybe your gym doesn't have air
conditioning and you live in the south
and you're like you know what [ __ ] that
i'm not going to be in that warehouse
gym in the month of july in the state of
alabama that's [ __ ] i'm not doing it
uh that's totally fine you can like
just doing a little resistance training
we're talking like
maybe three or four sets of like
push-ups pull-ups uh
bodyweight split squats per week
you will probably lose a little muscle
lose a little strength but you're gonna
maintain virtually all of your gains for
a long long period of time just by doing
a little bit of something so uh
yeah that's
that's what i have to say on the topic
in general up to a month off probably
fine uh if you do just a little bit of
training you can stretch that out to
eight months or you might even still be
able to make a little bit of progress
over
a month or two of severely diminished
training volume um but then you know on
the other extreme end complete
immobilization very very bad news you
lose a lot of muscle a lot of strength
very quickly the other big thing to
consider is age so you can get away with
time out of the gym a little bit easier
if you're younger
rather than older
yeah i i just have one thing to add here
a very common thing that you'll see is
someone will be like hey i'm gonna be
out of the gym for like six weeks
because of some
circumstance
uh
but
i'm gonna increase my protein intake and
so i'm going to be fine i'm going to
retain all my muscle because of that so
i cool i think it's important to
recognize like every step that you
mentioned every proactive step
involved
movement activity training
if you remove that activity that
training stimulus and think that you
know protein is going to get you out of
a bind here
the the evidence is terrible for that it
just doesn't seem to work uh so like
there have been studies where they do
some pretty um
they try to induce atrophy in a number
of different ways often with
immobilization uh increasing dietary
protein just doesn't seem to do anything
at all there are a couple studies
indicating that maybe possibly
leucine might do a little bit of
something kind of
but generally speaking it's just i i
wouldn't even bother with a protein or a
leucine intervention and a lot of times
um oddly enough like
it kind of backfires a little bit
because people will be so adamant about
getting an extra protein during this
period of low activity they actually
probably eat more calories than they
need and so then when they come back
they've still if it's a really extended
period of time and they've really
reduced their activity level they come
back and they have every bit of
loss of strength and muscularity that
they would have without the protein
intervention i mean it did not save them
any preservation of strength or muscle
but they also gained a little bit more
fat than they would have liked to so if
anything it kind of in terms of their
fitness goals sometimes it kind of digs
that whole paradoxically a little bit
deeper because it's like well i still
got to regain all that strength and
muscle and there's a little more fat to
lose that i didn't really plan for yeah
so
nutrition stuff i honestly wouldn't even
bother aside from just good healthy
nutrition practices for sure so really
the two big takeaways is
if if you're going on any sort of like
normal length vacation over the summer
you don't need to worry about it like
you you're you're not going to lose
enough muscle or strength to
to lose sleep over and when you when you
get back to the gym you're gonna get it
all back in a week or two like it's
totally fine don't worry about it
and if you are still worried about it
take
five minutes a day do one set of
push-ups one set of pull-ups one
reasonably hard set of split squats and
then go about your day
that that's that's going to maintain
your gains for
you know if
certainly for a two-week vacation
probably for like six months out of the
gym um
yeah that that's like that is the
ultimate security blanket just doing a
little bit of something it doesn't have
to be much just doing a little bit
consistently will
help you maintain the muscle and
strength you have very effectively for a
very long period of time yeah for sure
all right i think i'm going to answer
one q a question and then we'll wrap up
all right this episode's going to be a
little longer than normal but you know
it's free content so if you prefer
shorter episodes good news this is a
bonus double episode and you can
you can listen to it in two different
sittings um all right so i had a
question from alex
and uh the question was is there any
actual benefit to sauna use aside from
the fact that it just feels nice
uh first of all i wouldn't discount that
end there it's nice to do things that
feel nice so
like i personally
use so when i
started like getting serious about
trying to train around or kind of rehab
my hip and low back issues i joined a
new gym that just had more equipment
that would be more suitable for me and
uh it happened to be like one of those
nice gyms that has like a sauna and a
steam room and all that dude i use the
sauna all the time
explicitly because it feels nice and i
like it
so i don't want to discount that
application but the question is more
about
physiological benefits so first of all
sauna generally speaking there are going
to be different types there are dry
saunas and wet saunas uh generally
speaking
a wet sauna is going to be
over 70 degrees celsius or 160
fahrenheit usually with over 50
um with a dry sauna it's often going to
be 80 to 90 degrees celsius which is
like 176 to 194 fahrenheit usually much
lower humidity like 10 to 20 percent and
there are a number of different ways
that people do sauna bathing and that's
kind of the verb is sauna bathing so
finish style sauna often you're doing
one to three sessions of heat exposure
in the five to twenty minute range and
then uh you know it's finland so between
that you might go take a dip in a frigid
body of water go uh you know play in the
snow a little bit really cool down and
then get in for the next session or just
listen to the most brutal black metal on
this planet exactly absolutely uh and
dude finnish uh like sauna culture i'm
all about it dude uh i i was
finland was one of my first uh
international trips i ever took uh it's
probably like my first real
international trip i made it like two
miles into canada one time i don't know
if that really counts being from ohio
but um yeah i went to finland and uh
dude saunas are everywhere and it is so
cool i i wish that america would adopt
that um like even like at universities
and like the uh the faculty lounge there
will be a sauna in the lounge there next
to the coffee machine it's just really
cool
but anyway finish style sauna uh like i
said one to three sessions about five to
twenty minutes and between those
sessions you kind of get out and cool
off a little bit uh there are other uh
versions of sauna there's some different
infrared sauna techniques um there's a
type of infrared sauna use called
wand therapy in japan i'm certainly not
pronouncing that correctly but generally
speaking you know
with sauna you're talking about five to
maybe 30 minutes inside the sauna
breaking that up into multiple sessions
now physiologically sauna is really
fascinating because
there have been a number of review
papers and i'm going to link some of
those review papers in the show notes
that do identify some modest
physiological benefits and what's
interesting about sauna is the
mechanisms almost if you look at kind of
the physiological response to sauna
exposure and the kind of uh metabolic
and endocrine uh kind of snapshot of
what's going on
it almost looks like a bit of an
exercise mimetic like something that
kind of
mimics the signature of what we would
see with someone doing exercise so you
know we'll see like increased ampk and
glute 4 reductions in certain
inflammatory markers
acutely when you're in there you're
going to have an increase in heart rate
and sweat rate and cardiac output
notably without an increase in stroke
volume so that's a major difference
compared to exercise um but but yeah we
see like with chronic use uh we see
these reductions in inflammation to some
extent some changes in certain metabolic
parameters some changes in certain
cardiovascular parameters uh reductions
in reactive oxygen species so uh and
even changes in the way that the
endothelial cells function in the
vascular system so there are a lot of
mechanisms where you would look at sauna
and say
this uh kind of planned safe
safely planned exposure to heat stress
seems to be
influencing certain things that are kind
of similar to what
low amounts of exercise might do
so physiologically the response to sauna
exposure i think is really fascinating
and like i said i'm gonna link some
review papers in there uh one of the
best review papers uh well
this see this is a difficult thing for
me to share in the show notes
there is a review paper by dr rhonda
patrick
that goes over the mechanisms of sauna
and she was on she's been on some
podcasts lately talking about sauna and
i very much disagree with some of the
conclusions some of the practical
applications
i think that the potential benefits are
very overstated in terms of magnitude
but i am sharing the link because i
think it gives the most comprehensive uh
overview of the potential mechanisms and
actually the figures are very good
and i'm a sucker for good tables and
figures in a paper so my recommendation
is to look at that paper and read it
from the following context
if you were really adamant about
convincing me that sauna was super super
super important and effective how would
you justify it that's kind of how you
should read through that paper just to
get an idea of what mechanisms are at
play
but when it comes to the actual
magnitude of effect the kind of
tangible clinically relevant
health-related outcomes
i think the picture is a little bit more
it's a little bit more dicey it's a
little bit more messy it's not quite as
conclusive and robust and what we see in
the sauna literature is actually a
decent number of total papers but very
few randomized controlled trials uh
which is unfortunate because it is a
therapy that lends itself to randomized
controlled trials
so i very much do hope that they will
do more of these in the future while
also looking at different observational
techniques to to try to assess longer
term outcomes that you can't really look
at in an rct
but a lot of the
really really really positive findings
with like huge effect sizes about sauna
a lot of them are tied to one particular
study and one particular research group
that publishes from these findings
and uh
i you know these researchers do good
work i'm not like disparaging the work
uh and saying like oh this is terrible
research but it's really critical to
recognize this particular study is this
long-term observational study but sauna
use was actually determined based on a
one-time
self-report questionnaire that happened
like in the 80s
so they basically wow yeah they
basically brought them in and said like
how much do you currently use sauna
on this day in 1987 yeah and so then
they're doing these like 40-year
analyses of like who's dying and who's
not and what are they dying of and the
question is first of all to what extent
do your current sauna related practices
for one week in the 80s
necessarily reflect your lifelong
commitment to sauna exposure yeah
and then secondarily to what extent was
your sauna use
that week in the 80s
uh
to what extent
is that playing a causative role in your
health outcomes versus hey i
uh have an active social life i do sauna
with my friends because it's a thing we
do
uh i you know i've got great social
connections an awesome network of
friends and family i am healthy enough
to put myself in a very very hot room
for 30 minutes at a time very frequently
i'm at a spot in my life where i can
free up the time to do that and engage
in behaviors that i think are good for
my physical and mental health there are
so many potential instances of reverse
causation where healthier people are
doing sauna versus sauna creating
healthier people yeah well and i mean we
would also just need to know something
about finnish culture in the 1980s like
how was sauna viewed was it something
that like
uh the health authority said ooh maybe
don't do this it's bad for you or is it
something that they were saying like ooh
this is good you should do it it's it's
healthy for you because if it's the
latter then it could just be that like
people who are generally striving to be
healthy
were the people who were in the sauna a
lot in the 1980s and you know maybe they
kept getting in the sauna maybe they
didn't or you know maybe they adopted
any other number of generally healthy
behaviors
in pursuit of being healthy
i don't know how saunas were viewed in
finland in the 1980s yeah so so there's
a lot to
i basically just cautioned against
taking those particular findings and
saying oh look at this very clear
causative link between sauna use and
this particular outcome now those
studies do make sauna use look very very
good the magnitude of effect in some of
those studies is surprisingly large but
when you dig deeper into some of those
results they they were really making the
rounds a few weeks ago because they got
covered on a big podcast and people were
like oh yeah if you do this it's going
to cut your rate of
this outcome by like 30 and this outcome
by like 50
and if you dig deeper into those
findings what you find is that
those really large effect sizes that
were reported appeared to be unique to
particular subgroups of people who
uh
you know had
indicators of you know relatively poor
cardio metabolic health so like it was
the people who were
uh based on their metrics at baseline
they should have been relatively high
risk groups for those outcomes it looks
for the like for the people with the
worse state of fitness level and
cardiomedic metabolic health sauna
seemed to have the largest effects for
people who were doing sauna and already
had kind of a cardiometabolic and
fitness level profile that would be
correlated with good health and
longevity the effect sizes were really
not impressive for those folks so
sauna right now is getting kind of
popularized as this thing where if
you're a healthy person with a high
level of cardio respiratory fitness and
a great cardio metabolic health profile
if you do sauna you're going to get this
huge health benefit that's not really
compatible with the totality of the
evidence those benefits seem to be
mostly
within individuals of lower
cardio metabolic fitness or cardio
metabolic health status at baseline so
my overall assessment of sauna based on
the literature is the mechanisms are
fascinating and i like physiology
i think it is probably it probably has
modest positive health benefits related
to cardio metabolic health and
cardiovascular health i certainly don't
view it
as a replacement for exercise or
physical activity i think it's almost
like hey
it's better than nothing but not as good
as you know more traditional forms of
exercise to benefit cardiometabolic
outcomes and cardiovascular outcomes uh
i think if you're someone with a
low
cardiorespiratory fitness level who's at
high cardiometabolic health risk at
baseline
you might have to some extent an
additive effect of doing a little bit
more exercise and a little bit of sauna
in the mix
but as you start to get to a higher
fitness level i think it's more likely
that those health-related benefits of
sauna become
increasingly modest and potentially at
some point even a little bit redundant
in the context of someone who is at a
really high fitness level uh so in in
summary i think what you would expect
with sauna is nutri neutral to modestly
positive health outcomes um but but it's
certainly not a replacement i mean one
of the things that i mentioned is a
critical distinction is you know you do
get some of these
uh indicators that's like oh sauna does
this exercise also does that but the
fact that you have an increase in
cardiac output without an increase in
stroke volume the increase in stroke
volume is a really major driver of a lot
of the positive cardiovascular
adaptations that we make to aerobic type
exercise so yeah it's not like a full
exercise replacement but like i said
probably better than nothing and one of
the things i find most fascinating about
it
as i do it myself
i was reading a great review paper about
um
exercise and appetite
and they were suggesting in that review
paper that the increase in body heat
that we experienced during exercise
might play a causative role in
suppressing appetite after exercise
acutely
and it was it was hypothetical it was
speculative it was not something that i
would take to the bank but i have
noticed that when i do sauna
uh it does seem to transiently blunt my
appetite to some extent which i think is
really fascinating it's something i've
noticed with sauna but i don't
particularly notice with exercise to be
honest uh but anyway you know there's
there's a lot of interesting stuff
related to sauna and i'm hoping that
we'll get more randomized controlled
trials to kind of dig into some of these
mechanisms but i will say
an important thing to keep in mind is
that saunas are hot
and heat stress is a serious physical
physiological stressor so if you have
any kind of uh
you know noteworthy or relevant uh
medical condition you'll want to make
sure that you consult with a prof a
medical professional to make sure that
it is safe for you to engage in extended
periods of time in this level of heat
stress because it can be quite serious
you know i'm curious the the body heat
and appetite thing
i i would want to read that paper what
occurs to me because like i also don't
want to eat after
after i get really hot
but it's just because i'm sweaty and i
don't want to eat when i'm sweaty
because i feel like
i just feel slimy and i feel like i'm
just going to get sweat and muck all
over everything that i'm eating and so
like
i don't know
i one i wonder if you can
like completely shut down sweat
but uh still make people hot if you
would see if you would see the same
impact well good luck running that study
i'm sure the irb would love that we're
gonna
introduce heat stress and then remove
the human mechanism to actually
dissipate heat yeah just just figure out
how quickly the subjects in that study
can learn how to paint exactly yeah uh
yeah i'll put that that review in the
show notes that was talking more about
um
you know exercise and heat and appetite
that wasn't the main focus of the paper
it was one sub section um but yeah i'll
put that in the show notes and i'll send
it to you after the show and you can
take a look at it maybe we'll revisit on
the show later like i said that that to
me is something i was like oh that's an
interesting thing i do the sauna because
i like it but i have noticed that i do
have some some notable appetite
suppression for a couple hours afterward
um now
i'm not in a calorie deficit um i'm just
at maintenance level so
uh it's very possible that once you get
into a deficit it's just like whatever
you're still hungry like yeah
it is interesting like if there's one
thing you learn from bodybuilding it's
that a severe calorie deficit combined
with low body fat can cut through damn
near anything like yeah well
so after like
yeah after a hard workout in the heat
after i go play basketball whatever
i do want to consume calories like just
some sort of like calorific beverage
yeah but i don't want to put food in my
mouth yeah uh
so yeah i i feel like i feel like i am
experienced in experiencing
physiological hunger but i just feel
gross if i eat while i'm very sweaty
yeah well yeah we'll uh maybe revisit
that but
at the bare minimum i'll put that link
in the show notes and people can uh
engage in the controversy and form their
own opinion sounds good but yeah so sana
like i said neutral to modestly positive
health benefits i think it's uh a lovely
cultural practice i think it's very fun
and cool there seems to be a social
element in certain countries that that
is you know really cool like i kind of
wish we had it here uh and i love doing
sauna because i think it feels great and
like i said yeah maybe you get some
minor health benefits from it maybe not
but as long as there's no
contraindication as long as you don't
have a relevant medical issue that would
prevent you from using sauna you know i
certainly see no reason to uh restrict
yourself from doing something that can
be very enjoyable very relaxing and this
actually was funny so we've talked about
gym culture on the show before yeah um
so my girlfriend and i go to the same
gym
and she was
stunned to learn about what a men's
locker room is like at a gym yeah uh and
we go to the same gym so it's like a
perfectly like it's like a randomized
controlled trial because
there are two locker rooms in the same
exact building uh what is the difference
in culture within these rooms and
because i'll come back and tell her and
be like dude i almost died in the sauna
because i was chatting with this guy and
he just wouldn't stop talking like i i
was like having a heat stroke and like
dude i have to leave but because i'm
from the midwest i cannot be rude and so
i can't just be like hey dude i'm
leaving because i'm like gonna die here
but yeah like i've i've had to like be
like dude i'm i'm really sorry but i
must leave but like i've been in the
sauna and there have been these like
lively debates among like four or five
people about like
interest rates and the cost of a barrel
of oil and like we're out here just like
chatting it up and she's like i i could
hear a pin drop in the women's locker
room at any moment i've never spoken to
a human being there and i'm like dude i
can't get a word in in there yeah like
it is yeah apparently there is some
dynamic going on but uh yeah the getting
in the sauna is is just the chattiest
place that i've that i frequent on a
regular basis oh for sure um all right
so i think uh oh we gotta play the show
out to play us out i've got uh a little
music recommendation before the thunder
uh shuts us down here
so
oops so i moved to north carolina uh
several years ago that's close yeah that
is a very close storm
moved to north carolina uh
several years ago and i moved from ohio
and the thing about ohio is that it's
like
there's no unique culture to it really
at least the part that i lived in and so
when i moved to north carolina i was
fascinated by the different aspects of
north carolina culture like
in the outer banks there's like a
version of dance that is like specific
to north carolina uh i have no id i have
never heard of such a thing in ohio
there's a specific dialect the ocracoke
brogue and if you've never heard that
please
go to youtube and search ocracoke brogue
and listen to this dialect it is so
fascinating it's apparently a bunch of
scottish
people came into the outer banks kind of
settled on this island that was really
like you just stayed on the island like
they just kind of stayed put and created
their own little culture there in
ocracoke uh but it's an accent that i i
couldn't even begin to describe and
they've even developed their own kind of
vocabulary to go with it uh so i was
really fascinated by this kind of like
coastal culture that's been
cultivating in north carolina for for a
long time but also the appalachian
culture out west in the mountains uh and
one of the things that i loved about
moving to north carolina was that it's
not that rare when you're out in the
summer to hear a bluegrass band kind of
playing out uh you know and like at a
brewery or any kind of outdoor event
and so
bluegrass music uh i've really fallen in
love with it over the last decade or so
it's a really great musical tradition
with
fantastic instrumentation and really
great storytelling in the lyrics um the
the storytelling element is is a really
unique part of bluegrass to me i think
when well done the stories are are are
just really great it's really well
written songs uh and in terms of the
instrumentation uh i'm just a sucker for
two things
a great banjo and good vocal harmonies
and you're going to get plenty of both
with bluegrass so
in terms of bluegrass recommendations
maybe not necessarily what i would train
to on a regular basis but uh i i'd love
me some old crow medicine show
and willie watson who was in old crow
medicine show and then kind of split off
to do his own thing and obviously i'm
not like a bluegrass insider this is
like the most mainstream bluegrass band
you could possibly mention
but they're very good uh i also really
really love dave rawlings and gillian
welch they often play together uh and
then dave rawlings uh has kind of a band
project that that gillian uh
participates in often
and uh yeah dave rawlings and gillian
welch
very very good singers tremendous
harmony between them uh and dave
rawlings is
he is
excellent at the guitar but in a very
sneaky way it's like you have to listen
closely and you'll be like oh my god
that was
that was really wild and then if you
watch him play
you get this even greater uh
appreciation for how much skill is
required to play the songs that he plays
on the guitar so uh for a major change
of change of pace from our progressive
metal conversation uh dave rawlings
gillian welch old crow medicine show and
willie watson really great opportunities
to check out some bluegrass and i hope
you like it yeah if you're if you're one
of the people who says like you know
what i
i conceptually like the idea of country
music but you know modern country music
on the radio i don't like it it all
sounds the same like it's it's mass
produced corporate garbage but like
the old stuff that's where it's at uh
when that musical tradition split kind
of what we now think of as country went
one way and what we now think of as
bluegrass and folk when another way yeah
so yeah if you like uh if you like
putting on old country records and
you're like man why don't they make
music like this anymore yeah they make
something like it and uh and you can
probably find it in the genres of either
folk or bluegrass yeah definitely
all right so that does it for this
episode of the stronger by science
podcast as always thank you for
listening and we will be back
next week with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you